le québec forme une nation distincte les
de ses choix
cette semaine françois legault à
formuler ses demandes politiques aux
chefs des partis présentement en
campagne électorale
on en discute ce soir avec mia homsy
directrice de l'institut du québec
bonsoir ça on a l'impression qu'on ne
parle un petit peu toute la semaine
notamment de la déclaration de revenus
et c'est que monsieur legault a pas fait
de demande chiffrée
est ce que c'est votre perception
également selon moi c'est pas juste une
impression j'ai cherché partout que je
vois des demandes qui sont très
différentes des demandes habituellement
habituel du québec historique historique
habituellement les gouvernements
demandent de l'argent pour les
infrastructures pour la santé
puis en péréquation cette année c'est
surtout des demandes au niveau du
rapatriement de pouvoirs en migration
est même en environnement au niveau de
la déclaration d'impôt unique et terra
mais au niveau des chiffres puis de
l'argent tout ce qu'on voit c'est plus
d'argent santé mais c'est pas précisé
nécessairement combien donc c'est un
changement majeur de type de demande de
gouvernements province du québec au
gouvernement fédéral donc aller chercher
plus de pouvoir aller chercher plus
d'autonomie en quelque sorte un message
très politique au final mais parlons
quand même de l'immigration plus de
pouvoir en immigration
est ce que ce serait plus simple plus
efficace pour le québec d'avoir plus de
pouvoir sur les migrations économiques
sur les travailleurs temporaires
notamment
oui en fait que deux demandes principal
c'est que la quête s'est engagé à passer
dans environ 50000 immigrants à 40
milles puis à l'airé augmenter sauf que
le pouvoir en ce moment du gouvernement
s et sur l'ensemble le chiffre global
mais pas sur chacune des catégories donc
les catégories sur les immigrants
économiques ensuite que le regroupement
familial et les réfugiés
le gouvernement ne contrôle pas le
nombre de réfugiés et de regroupement
familial par année donc quand tu décides
de réduire le nombre total de l'impact
et surtout sur les travailleurs les
coloniser une grande économie voilà ce
qu'ils s'intègrent plus facilement
marché du travail qui ont des mers
conditions salariales
qui répondent le plus aux besoins de
main d'oeuvre donc c'est pour ça que sur
cet aspect là le premier ministre
aimerait avoir plus d'autonomie et sur
l'autre aspect c'est les travailleurs
temporaires avec la candide postes
vacants qui est en hausse au québec on
est à 140 milles en ce moment mais le
travailleur temporaire peut être une
solution très efficace c'est peut-être
plus rapide aussi mais en ce moment le
processus est très lourd et compliqué
c'est coûteux pour les employeurs
doivent démontrer les besoins
une fois au québec ensuite ça vaut
fédéral donc c'est long et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya une demande de rapatrier au
québec
mais ce serait donc plus efficace si le
québec contrôler tout cela au lieu
d'être en ce moment des daubes est alors
oui c'est sûr que ce serait plus
efficace si ça passait juste par un
ministère ou un gouvernement que de
faire le travail en double ce qui
rallonge considérablement le délai dans
les domaines ya également les
entreprises à charte fédérale qu'il soit
désormais sujette ya la loi 101
il ya on a réitéré l'instauration d'une
seule déclaration de revenu unique nous
en avons parlé cette semaine je n'ai pas
beaucoup entendu l'enjeu sur les
transferts fédéraux c'est certain qu'on
va parler de péréquation mais des
transferts fédéraux en santé notamment
pourquoi le premier ministre n'en
parlent pas davantage d'autant que ces
transferts ralentissent exactement il
dit que c'était des enjeux important
mais pas prioritaire puis l'argent santé
dans sont les deux principaux transferts
qui viennent du gouvernement fédéral au
québec c'est la péréquation et les
transferts canadien pour la santé mais
c'est intéressant parce que
historiquement le gouvernement fédéral
quand ils disent il faut que les
services de santé soit universel gratuit
public
on va financer la moitié de ce que ça
vous coûte donc 7 500 euros ça a diminué
avec le temps ça a était 25% et
maintenant on est rendu à 22%
rubens et c'est alors que les provinces
doivent quand même respecter les mêmes
obligations la loi canadienne sur la
santé
et en plus les populations vieillissent
pour qu on entend moins parler c'est une
bonne question parce que il ya eu il ya
quelques années un front commun des
provinces contre la décision du fédéral
de réduire la croissance des transferts
en santé sté 6% par année l'augmentation
puis sous le gouvernement harper la
décision avait été prise de réduire sa
au pib et avec un plancher de 3 % puis
le pib nominal binominal mais avec les
dernières années la croissance qu'a eu
ça a été en moyenne autour de 3 4% la
croissance de ces transferts le mais les
provinces doivent gérer une population
qui vieillit pour tout mais la majorité
est donc une très forte pression sur les
coûts et donc il ya un effet il ya moins
de transferts depuis quelques années on
note les transferts la croissance des
transferts est plus lente alors que les
coûts sur la pression sur les systèmes
de prêts de santé des provinces et plus
élevé le gouvernement du québec dit nous
on en a besoin d'à peu près 5 % de
croissance des transferts pas 3 po 4 et
donc ça fait un manque à gagner pour le
quitter un manque à gagner serait même
encore ça depuis que la formule
inchangée
donc depuis un ou deux ans sacré manque
à gagner par rapport à ce que ça arrêté
sous l'ancien l'ancienne entente
donc au lieu d'augmenter de 6 % avec une
croissance de 3 4%
et si on projette sur plusieurs années
le gouvernement du québec estimé apollon
tanks étaient environ une douzaine de
milliards qui allait lui manquer
que fait le gouvernement fédéral plutôt
que d'envoyer les transferts aux
provinces que fait le gouvernement
fédéral avec cet argent là en fait le
gouvernement fédéral et aux provinces on
vous donne 6 % de croissance de
transferts en santé puis semble pas
avoir vraiment d'amélioration de vos
systèmes dans les provinces on voit pas
une amélioration on voit pas une base
des listes d'attentes on voit pas une
hausse de productivité donc ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'on veut décider nous-mêmes
- ce qu'on met l'argent par exemple la
santé mentale les soins à domicile
puis le plus nouvellement le
gouvernement semble vouloir le dire j'ai
très spécifiquement vers les médicaments
avec la nouvelle assurance médicaments
qui veut proposer ce c'est l'engagement
fort en santé du gouvernement fédéral
maison aucun intérêt politique
pour les provinces en font pas un plat
ils vont jamais augmenter ce transfert
et ce n'est pas prioritaire donc dit le
premier ministre le gault millau mais
c'est merci beaucoup merci merci